I'm having our students be prepared to
face vela it's really important because
I think it's essential to the design
process and I we have a professor Rob
Miller came in to do a lecture on user
centered design very early on in this
semester where we basically present to
them this design model of you know where
you do it a bit of design which means
you quickly come up with a prototype you
fail as fast as possible you figure out
where everything is going wrong and then
you make a second prototype you know and
you keep going round and round and round
this circle until you reach that perfect
prototype at the end of the day and so I
think they knew from the start that they
were going to have to just keep making
things and seeing how they were going to
go around and so yeah failure became
very entrenched part of the design
process in fact we told them right from
the start we expect you to have three
prototypes at least by the end of the
semester and these are when your
prototypes should be ready by and these
are the weeks where you will get to test
them and every week they had to come
back and tell them entras where things
went well and where things didn't go
well according to some set of success
metrics yeah I think the design review
these midterm panels were really just
that to try to get feedback on the
design or really explain the progress
that they had made so far and so I think
that that was a big reason why we did
that I think having mentors this year
was helpful on this front as well the
mentors were pretty in touch with how
teams were progressing we had each team
fill out this little form every week
explaining what was going well and what
they needed help with so I think a big
part of it was kind of creating the
culture that it doesn't have to go
perfectly well every week there can be
setbacks there can be different
challenges or obstacles to overcome but
we're here to you know work through them
and figure out how to deal with this
situation or brainstorm some ideas one
of the other things that we tried this
year was to have these lightning updates
at the end of every week's lab just to
keep
I just to inform the rest of the class
where you're at and what you were trying
what progress you were making I think
this may be set up a little bit of sort
of friendly competition to kind of see
where other projects are at but also I
think helped maybe the class feel like
we're all in this together I suppose
it's not always going to be easy maybe
there's logistics challenges maybe
there's design challenges maybe there's
other sorts of things so I think
students were pretty open to sharing
honestly what their progress was and
what they were what they were doing at
least that's what we we tried to do hope
so we don't get feedback from students
though that the Lightning updates might
have been too regular and they did say
that it would have been nice to have it
once every two weeks instead of every
week and that that would just give them
more time to work together as a team and
we realized too that for our students
being able to do group work outside of
class is actually difficult because they
all have such busy schedules so any time
they had like structure time within a
class teachers do group work together
that was really valuable for them